i just had never seen anybody
that tall
but the skill that he had was was just
off the charts all of us were like oh
man this dude is really coming
[Music]
you know the first thing you notice
about him of course is his size in terms
of being you know seven feet tall but
then you realize like what a gifted
passer he is not only a gifted pastor
but also a gifted ball handler became a
champion we watched them dominate in the
finals seven footers like that they
don't come along that often and when
they do they really do change the game
there's been a lot of comparisons when
people talk about giannis the one player
that really reminds me a lot of giannis
is ralph sampson seven foot four from
the houston rockets number 50 ralph
sampson how are you
he's going to redefine how to play big
guard
samson
nice move outside
back from mcrae bank
oh what a running slam jam most people
don't realize you know ralph sampson was
7-4 bringing the ball up the court
making passes shooting jump shots
dunking on you right hand in left hand i
just had never seen anybody that tall
but the skill that he had was was just
off the charts bill russell made the
comment that ralph sampson if he reaches
his potential he will be talked about
and considered one of the greatest
players to ever play one second
on the
clock samson has given the houston
rockets the western conference
championship we were all watching it on
on television because uh you know as
lakers against the rockets we knew how
dominant a player ralph was becoming and
he was playing against kareem
abdul-jabbar ralph was you know kind of
having his way with the lakers all of us
were like oh man this this dude is
really coming that rockets team i mean
you talk about the twin towers
they were the real twin towers this is
how dominant ralph sampson was
for that little short period of time
before he got injured if ralph sampson
had not got hurt basketball history
would be so drastically different don't
know what would have happened with the
celtics would they have continued with
the lakers have continued in the west if
he stays healthy he and elijah won i
don't think there was a force capable of
competing with those two here's the ali
from magic johnson what a joy for a guy
like magic johnson to lay the ball up
there and know that it's not going to be
missed so we're in indianapolis and i
won a championship in indiana larry bird
coming home you got two hoosier legends
coming back to play in indianapolis i'll
never forget you know magic and ralph
sampson they just took over the game it
was one thing to have
ralph sampson being so amazing
himself as a player in his second year
but it was just totally totally totally
unfair
to pair him with magic johnson you know
you talk about two unique
freak athletes at their position doing
things that the nba hadn't seen and then
you put them on the same team in the
magic that they created you know for
those 48 minutes they killed us and
ralph was great so i want everyone out
there to really understand we're
watching greatness happen here today but
the greatness that was going on back
then with the size and the uniqueness of
players was just as good as it is today
in some cases may even be better and
ralph sampson was one of us
and and again it's like you know he's
he's 7-4 so he's kind of like hey man
you
you you all right hey it's uh it's so
good to see you